welcome everyone they put us back in the
corner because they knew we're they
loose cannon so we're in the back
hope you're woken up from your lunch
welcome everyone thanks for coming today
I'm Gus Coe styler and I look after
cultivating our relationships with a
venture capital and startup community on
behalf of Google and Android Google Play
and Android and my colleague is Ellie
powers we'll take the second half who
leads our developer product team here
the two of us have been spending a lot
of time with startups this year so I'd
like to ask how many people work at
startups who are in the crowd get a show
of hands awesome like it's less than a
hundred people kind of companies that's
a great year in the right place so we're
here to talk to you about how many of
you are succeeding on Google Play and
why more and more are launching on
Android and SIM shipping your apps and
to start you could say this is a bit of
a passion area for me personally I spent
a good chunk of my career at mobile
startups most recently ones like inkling
and Flipboard and now I get to sit on
the other side of the fence where my
team is focused exclusively on helping
startup succeed and making it feel like
less of a black art so while the team is
new in just the last few months we've
already it's already become obvious to
Ellie and myself that there are some
recurring themes we hear from startups
that come to Android and so we'd like to
discuss those with you here specifically
we broke the recurring themes down into
three buckets that we would label as
follows reach the next billion and
iteration and we'll spend our time
drilling down on how to get the most out
of those and we'll also share three case
studies of startups who are really
representing those themes well and
demonstrating best practices in these
areas so let's get started with reach
and the first billion before we go on to
the next billion you've probably heard
of benedict evans over at Andreessen
Horowitz he's one of my personal
personal
favorite mobile pundits in the mobile
tech world he's prolific with his
dispatches on subject of mobile eating
the world so a few months ago he said
this mobile is the first universal tech
product and he was referring to the data
on the following slide and he points out
some projections from various sources
specifically global population on the
left of nearly 8 billion people
projected in 2020 and the population of
people over 16 years old at 6 billion
and finally smartphones projected at 5
billion in 2020 way further on the left
and in the expected growth you can see
in in purple between 2015 and 2020 his
point is in my point is that smartphones
are starting to get close to nearly
reaching everyone on the planet and
that's kind of a big deal it's pretty
profound and non-trivial you when when
you consider how little little effort is
required to make and sell products that
reach nearly everyone and there's never
really been a similar kind of product or
platform sure coca-cola bicycles and
refrigerators are neat too and they have
great reach but they're not quite the
same demo democratizing platforms for
allowing the world to communicate
transact and disseminate information in
quite the same way so now when we think
about Android and how it factors into
that global reach
last year Android crossed a pretty huge
threshold with over a billion devices
shipped around the world and now you can
see us log in 1.4 billion 30-day actives
and we've seen 1.5 million Android
devices being activated daily and a
continued platform momentum of 400 OEMs
and 500 operators on the platform it's
pretty incredible that play was launched
just over four years ago while Android
is expanding the footprint of device
availability plays helping developers
build businesses across the globe and
it's growing pretty fast in its own
right way back was that when I was in
your shoes back at mobile app startups
and Android was just getting started
in the echo chamber here in the valley
it was still kind of
fashionable to pick on Android and say
it Lac billion dollar startup success
stories and then something funny
happened companies like whatsapp and
uber line King Flipkart Spotify
supercell started sprouting up and these
insane growth trajectories and have
become massive global brands in their
own right ask any of those companies now
if Android is important to their
business and I think they'll agree my
point is this my experience that
startups made it clear that a founders
job is fundamentally to challenge the
status quo thinking and observe what is
changing around you ask yourself what
you know to be true in the future and
execute relentlessly on your vision so
in that light I'd ask you all to take a
hard look at Android when you're getting
started on your next idea and consider
how reach might factor heavily in your
startups growth objectives of course
many of you have already asked these
questions and that's why you're here
today and so keep plugging away on
Android that's awesome once you've made
your Android platform decision what
should you do next to realize the full
benefits of smart phone reach well
there's a couple things you need to know
to get there and our experience these
are the first few things you should be
thinking about building for reach so
let's begin with material the last
session was all about material and there
was you know code on slides and all that
stuff we're not gonna do that here today
but I did want to point this one out
because maybe it's not immediately
obvious but material has been crucial
for startups trying to attain reach and
in that material offers one universal
language for navigation and interaction
that is becoming second nature for
Android users and I myself having come
from those startups I was skeptical
about material when they first told me
about it and felt like you know our app
should look the same across all
platforms and that kind of thing but you
know basically what what I've learned is
that by using material you've already
had a huge head start on using a design
that most of those million billion plus
users around the world already
understand and in a way that that is so
prevalent that it's now making its way
on to other platforms as well
as a result developers are seeing leaps
and engagement and conversion rates
across the board when they implement it
and you can see some of the great
examples here apps like the Bleak music
match Trello seeing some notable
increases in time and activity in their
apps and so yes material is cool but
also think from the business side about
it being this common language that
everybody gets while startups told us
material design was cool when we first
announced it you also told us that it
was a little hard to know where to get
started and that she wanted more
resources to make building material apps
easier and so we totally heard you and
over the past few years we've been
rolling out a bunch of new resources
that you can find at design google.com I
won't go into all the details of all
these things here given the last
presentation probably went into great
depth there but that's a hub you can go
find resources from another thing a lot
of stops worry about when they're
approaching Android for the first time
is device compatibility last year at
Google i/o we announced cloud test lab
in beta and this year we're taking the
training wheels off and moving it into
firebase and as you'd expect firebase
test lab is integrated with many
different tools so you can bring it into
your workflow easily I'm sure some of
you have product into other sessions on
firebase already and I would urge you as
a startup to really think about this
platform because it's it's it's got so
many different things in it wrapped up
into one great package whereas you know
companies that are a little further
along tend to specialize in the tools
they use so firebase is is especially
well-suited to startups who are just
figuring it out in Google Play all alpha
and beta apps are tested against a
representative range of devices profiles
in the cloud this test is completely
automated so you don't need to write
test scripts you can detect where
they're there any obvious issues on
these devices before rolling out your
app to all users and you can now enable
this from within the dev console the
best part of the base level of this is
that it's
totally free which is awesome after
trying the pre-launch report in the deaf
console the next thing developers say
they want is to run exactly the set of
tests they want on a specific set of
devices and they'll be a way to do that
too you'll be able to write custom test
scripts and run them on physical or
virtual devices you choose you can even
do that from Android studio your other
continuous integration systems once you
have a good sense that your product is
working another great way to grow Reach
is to obviously expand to other
countries globally you'll need to think
about localizing your app and your Play
Store listing from within the dev
console we provide tools and
recommendations to help you translate
your app across global global markets
take Netflix for example they recently
had a lot of press about globalizing
their app and you know they didn't just
translate their title and app
description but also made sure screen
shots and video trailers accurately
represented the app in all markets
pricing also an area you want to
consider to make sure your price
translates for local expectations making
sure your you know price doesn't look
like it's like a dollar 73 like here or
the cultural equivalent of that which
you know differs by country what the
what the sort of standards are around
pricing and so we help you could figure
that out
automatically for example we saw 2x
lifts you can see here in Japan for
those that round it to the nearest yen
so this is pretty cool
so now that you've heard more about
tactical advice on extracting benefits
of reach out of Android let's hear more
from a start-up developer who's been
capitalizing on some of those
opportunities we videos a start-up right
here in our backyard and has some
relevant experience to share glute video
was founded with the vision of making
digital storytelling and video creation
accessible to anyone anywhere
so let me for certain Android we clearly
saw that there wasn't a compelling
application for video creation
combine that with vast world of Android
platforms we decided to grow Android
first since then the majority of our
investment and smartphone development
has been and what separates us from
other applications on Android is that we
TV the full capability of the device in
our application you are able to take
different flips trim them and we were
able to do that because the Android
platform gave us access to the OpenGL
layer which a lot of the real-time
rendering and previewing since the
launch of a new application mobile
monetization is done very well for us
driving on Android has doubled every 2
minutes almost 85% of our users are on
implement with launched a material
design we decided to redo the
application and redo the user experience
and take it up to the next level
many of the material design concept
really resonated with us we were really
able to create the device full
experience for our users and as a result
we saw 100% increase
user engagement being able to reply to
refuse it's a great feature every day we
go through every single review and
analyze the data that's coming in and
most importantly if somebody who's
having a problem we can help right away
and in such a games feeling when you can
see someone who gave you one star
reviews converting that for five stars
we love running experiments on the Play
Store for example just recently we
updated our screenshots we tweaked the
colors the text and also increase in
conversion up to 50% making it available
in different languages is critical for
you to succeed in global market we saw
increase in our installs up to the
current percent in some regions after
revised our app and the Play Store
descriptions recently revisit our
purchases world in the app we wanted to
see we can converge more people to buy
our opinion products we decided to
change colors of the background on size
way out of the elements we were able to
deploy quickly in iterate trusted within
a few days and we saw the increase up to
60% in conversion rate the Android
platform has been a great platform for
us to iterate through our evolution with
a fast app publishing process Play Store
listing experiments feedback from users
and monetization using Google Wallet
this has led to a tremendous increase
and success with install and ready
cool
so we talked a little bit about reach
and the last billion so let's talk about
getting to the next billion that will
likely come online for the first time on
mobile in emerging markets in a sense
we've been spoiled by tech in the
developed world and while we are valuing
our cars ooh bring around town or during
dinner delivery and frolicking with
spirit guide butcher in the Black Rock
Desert it's easy to forget that phones
being purchased in the developing world
could be somebody's first computer first
source of books education health advice
access to e-commerce news microfinance
or entrepreneurial inspiration well it
might feel like these markets are behind
leapfrogging opportunities are being
created as some are learning to transact
globally for the first time on mobile
not desktop and hence their behavior is
mobile first by default Fred Wilson at
Union Square Ventures recently called
out this opportunity in a blog post
called the second smartphone revolution
where he was specifically referencing
the transformational mobile impact in
emerging markets he asked whether the
winners in the next phase would come
from Silicon Valley or from the local
developing world it's up to you to find
out but I'm incredibly excited to see
how both sets of founders go and solve
some of the some of the incredible new
challenges in emerging markets with
their apps coincidentally he too
referenced Benedict Evans in that
article here who says yes everyone and
points out that the incredible reach of
mobile as a percentage of coverage of
the African population is surpassing
even grid electricity in soon clean
water he also points out the the the
role of Android and it's affordability
which helps drive this transformational
reach and access consider that while the
developed world has created a lot of
solutions for first world problems and
is closer to reaching device saturation
there's a lot of blank space for
expansion in the developing world where
the next billion will come from and
where the problems outside of our little
echo
chamber can be far more profound and
life-changing to solve in other words a
whole new wave of innovation is just
beginning not just at the level of
luxury and convenience but from the
bottom of Maslow's hierarchy of needs
all the way to the top putting that back
in context of reach to real people the
projections are that 1.2 billion new
users will come online in emerging
markets by 2018 so what can you do to
reach them with your new ideas first
understand some of the constraints and
best practices designed for we've done a
lot of talking here this week about the
next billion but you know obviously the
slower data connections users that pay
as they go paying closer attention to
their consumption disconnected scenarios
and opportunities for offline modes and
caching low-end devices with different
you know lower storage and battery specs
meaning you want to keep apk updates
mises small and and other other notable
things which brings me to some things we
have done recently with play to eat our
own dog food and develop solutions to
some of these challenges ourselves
specifically we've been working to
automatically make the store more
efficient for you given the constraints
I just shared first we've been improving
our identification and promotion of
locally relevant apps if your app meets
the needs of emerging markets and for
example works well on slow connections
supports local languages
we'll make sure users find your app
second we've been working to make the
store more data efficient so Google Play
is investing and making updates smaller
as you can see here when you update your
app Play computes the difference from
the older version we've also updated the
store UI to show the Delta in size that
needs to be downloaded by the user
instead of the entire app size updates
can be really small and so this helps
users get less nervous about the size of
the download last but not least payments
in the last 12 months we enabled 61 new
forms of payment 32 markets which means
that 400 million people have access to
new form of payment just a zoom in on
one example of a roll out of DC V direct
carrier billing in Indonesia you can see
the crazy inflection point here where we
rolled it out represents a 4x increase
in buyer growth we've seen very similar
results in other countries like Turkey
Saudi Arabia and the UAE we recommend
running promotions in your apps to get a
share of that excitement when we launch
new payment support in those countries
as I mentioned you can sell your app in
130 countries now surprisingly the more
locally relevant payment methods we add
the more users become buyers and you can
see some of the specific uplift metrics
here most notably 30 percent
year-over-year growth and developers
international sales and some big
movements here in various markets like
Germany Russia and in Hong Kong
purchasing behavior in particular vary
significantly between markets so to
provide developers with more flexibility
we've worked to adapt Google Play
pricing options to better suit local
purchasing power parity levels and make
content more accessible following a
successful pilot in India earlier this
year or yeah earlier this year today
developers have the option to reduce the
price of their premium titles and in-app
products in 17 more countries to new
minimum thresholds like the ones you can
see here in this example you can see the
impact of lower prices more in line with
local markets resulted in a hundred and
thirty six percent increase spike in
orders which overcame the drop in price
with volume from an overall gain of 27
percent and revenue so you're absolutely
reaching more people and still making
more money so with that I hope you're
starting to get the sense of this theme
of how relentlessly our teams are
working to pass along big improvements
to the platform and how passionate we
are about investing in our developer
community
I'd like to transition into another
startup story this time sendee based in
Kenya solving for challenges of local
delivery and very crowded City
like nairobi go ahead and play Cindy is
a Kenyan company we connect customers
and logistics providers one of them
differently is figuring out the last
knowledge is six which is a problem in
most developing countries I mean we
don't have things like addresses here
being able to use technology to solve a
problem that really nobody has been able
to solve in this region is probably the
most exciting Beach sandy has 200 apps
one for the customers and one for the
drivers great thing about sandy is
you're able to drop pins for your pick
up on top of locations so it's easier
for you to identify it Namah rather than
enter in an actual address we went with
Android because majority of the users in
Kenya East Africans hundred phones and
the fact that a process partially doing
that continuous deployment to customize
is much faster on our platform
other startup that is constantly trying
new things we tend to roll out features
a lot cold feature in the Google Play
Developer console is the alpha and beta
testing groups we normally roll out our
new versions of the app to groups that
help us test and get as many bugs as
possible before the app goes into final
release most people love it when the UI
flow is as easy to use as possible
material design offers a very simple
language for people to understand and we
found that mostly and appreciated when
developing apps for the Canon market
there are certain things that you need
to consider you need to make sure that
your apk size is not too much because
most people don't have a lot of storage
space we also need to check the amount
of data the opposition because people
are very sensitive the amount of data
they use but she usage is also very
important people don't have the luxury
of plugging in their phones all the time
one of the key things most building
trust among your users so one of the
things we did in the beginning is
provide free delivery to customers the
other way of building trust is making
sure that we keep the customer they know
where the drivers it's through our
Android pub the way we've utilized the
Google Play Developer console to
establish user trust is that first we
make sure that all ratings on the Play
Store are high we also rely on
statistics such as a number of crashes
per equation that is very helpful for me
as a developer to know more bugs I
should escalate and fix as quickly as
possible
I think integration with local payments
is very very key as well to the success
of customers using your product over 90
percent of our customers pay for
services using
we have been seeing very financial
growth within the company we've grown
from a team of three to igniting more
about 23 people being able not only to
have an impact to the end-user but also
to the drivers in our platform so giving
them an income that they aren't able to
earn a few months ago
is really something that is touching for
me as a person I feel that we are
driving the economy in the neatest way
possible but we're still driving the
economy which is enough for me so cool
I just love you know we get so wrapped
up and the stuff in our back yard here
in Silicon Valley and it's awesome to
see startups all over the world solving
very diverse sets of problems and I just
see that there's so much more
opportunity there for the next phase if
the next billion in emerging markets is
of strong interest to you I also
encourage you to stick around for the
next session which will go into detail
on initiatives in progress we are making
to open up those markets next up is
Ellie who you might recognize from the
keynote on instant apps yesterday and
then play stuff this morning and Ellie
it's all yours
thanks very much Gus so one of the most
exciting things that Gus alluded to a
little bit earlier that my team has been
doing this year is you know we make
Google Play and the developer console
for so many different types of
developers right big companies small
companies countries here in Mountain
View countries and Kendra Kenya all
sorts of different developers and the
new emphasis we really put on in this
past year was to work with startups
specifically and so Gus's team has had a
big outreach program where we try to go
and actually meet with more startups
like all of you to understand you know
what information do you need to be
successful and also for my team how can
we go and refine the products that we
offer to all of you and so what I'm here
to talk about today is basically this
idea of iteration right and here at
Google we got really I guess famous for
you know having Gmail as a beta for a
long time you know we didn't know what
color to make the links on google.com
search a decade ago so we ran
experiments right we love to be
data-driven
we love to iterate we love to try new
things but also get a lot of user
feedback in order to improve and we
think that that's something that even
now there are a big company that we have
in common with a lot of startups and so
we want to make it really possible for
all of you to be able to do the same
things to be able to gather user
feedback really easily which as you know
is so critical in the early days of your
company and also to be able to try new
things
iterate rapidly and be able to get them
out for users again so we really want to
empower all of you and so what we're
gonna do is to go through a couple of
the different products some of them are
mentioned in some of the videos before
to really talk about what you should
know about as a start-up and the reason
we're giving this talk is we have a lot
of people that we run into at different
startup events and they go beta testing
I never even heard of that if only I had
known or really I can reply to my users
reviews if only I had known and so our
goal today is to try to make sure all of
you here are aware of the tool kit that
we offer on Google Play so Gus actually
introduced me to the saying recently if
you want to go fast go alone but if you
want to go far go
together and what I really like about
this is that what we want to do is to go
to go it with you and to help you go
faster and we hope that through working
with Google Play you'll be able to go
together and also go twice as fast so
we're gonna talk about four different
types of tools that are the most unique
things that we have to offer developers
especially startups on Google Play so
let's get started
so Google Play works a little bit
differently right and I think one of the
things that people need to know
especially if they've been on other app
platforms before is Google Play actually
has some things that are a little bit
different about it so the earlier in
your life you can find out about all the
different features that we have that may
actually change how you want to move
through your product development cycle
so the first thing that's important to
know is that for any of you who have an
app on Google Play does anyone have an
app on Google Play today by the way ok
does anyone have an app that's still in
stealth mode or not on Google Play yet a
couple folks so well we're hoping to
reach you a little bit earlier so the
most important thing for you to know is
that you can publish your app on Play
any time you want and developers tell us
year after year that's one of the most
important things to them is it all of
you are in control about when you can
publish your app there's no you know big
weight or anything like that
and the next thing that you want to
think about after that is this idea of
beta testing and staged rollouts so you
know at Google we have an app we have
lots of apps and when we release them we
don't want to put them out there to all
the users with just the initial version
right what we want to do is to kind of
roll them out more progressively and to
get feedback along the way so these two
tools beta testing and staged rollouts
are unique tools on Play that you can
use to make sure that you get a really
high quality result and also kind of
take control of your rollout and so we
want to walk you through how this is and
what we see from a lot of our most
successful developers is they actually
use these products every day the beta
testing and the staged rollouts so for
example at Google but basically every
app update we roll out we use staged
rollouts and we think that even startups
can benefit from these sorts of things
as well we see when you use these
practices you can
with a much higher quality result higher
quality app and a much better business
return as well so let's start by talking
about beta testing is anyone here
running a beta test or everyone run one
in the past that's awesome so we
actually see with some of our most
popular apps the top thousand apps on
Google Play 60% of them are running a
beta test right now and so if you
haven't tried a beta test before here's
basically the idea you can distribute
your app to a subset of users and then
you can get feedback earlier rather than
just launching it to everyone with beta
testing what's important here is users
actually need to opt in and say yes I
want to be a tester and so this can be
really important because it's not going
to be a completely representative sample
but it will be kind of self selecting
power users people who are willing to
put up with bugs and ideally also give
you feedback about how you need to
improve so you can test two different
versions we call them alpha and beta you
can view stats about them and it's a
great thing to do before you roll out in
production so let's talk about some of
the unique features here so users who
are in a beta or alpha test cannot
actually leave you a review so this is
important you don't want them to leak
anything or to hurt your star rating
that won't happen if someone's opted in
to be a tester they can't give you
reviews so we want to go through a
couple wait a couple of the pieces of
feedback we've gotten over the years to
clear up any misconceptions that might
be out there so the most common thing we
heard from you after we rolled up beta
testing was okay this is cool but I want
to make it a lot easier to manage who's
in and out of my beta test so last year
we announced something called open and
closed betas so if you want to allow
anyone to join your beta you can create
what's called an open beta test this way
you'll just be able to let anyone join
and actually as of this week now users
can opt-in directly to your open beta
tests on your page in the Play Store
your second option if you still want to
keep it in stealth mode is to do what we
call a closed beta so in addition to
Google Groups and Google+ communities
you can also special specify a list of
email addresses so that allows you to
control only these people get access to
my alpha or beta test so by the way if
you haven't checked out yet like that's
what it's actually going to look like in
the place
store so for all of you who have a beta
test and open beta on play go check it
out and then you may want to update some
of your documentation to your beta
testers about how they can opt in and we
think this will make it a lot easier and
also for anyone who already has your app
installed if they happen to peruse your
page in the Play Store again they might
see this and it'll make it a lot easier
for you to get more folks in your betas
now we mentioned earlier that when
people are in a beta they can't leave
you a review right super important and
for you know the whole time the beta
testing has been out there developers
can collect feedback from users in a
whole range of ways some people put some
sort of a form in the app itself others
provide an email address for collecting
feedback other people have a discussion
forum and we added one new option this
week which is that users will be able to
give you private feedback through the
Play Store so they go to the Play Store
and it's in the same place where they
would be leaving a review but it's
actually private feedback so you can see
here that this user in the place or has
provided private feedback to the
developer and when you go into the
developer console you'll be able to see
the private beta feedback there as well
and again this is not shown publicly it
does not attack you know effect your
apps rating in any way so back to the
earlier point about going fast and going
together we announced earlier this week
something that we're calling early
access and what this is is this is a
special place in the Play Store where
users early adopter users who want to
try out the latest and greatest stuff
can go to see apps that are actually in
beta and the reason we launched this was
we heard from a lot of startups Wow
beta testing sounds great I'd love to
get a bunch of people giving me early
feedback on my app but I'm a startup I
don't even have many users how could I
possibly grow a group of beta testers so
what we sided to do was to identify some
of the most exciting apps that are out
there many of them from startups and all
of them haven't really been made
publicly available on Google Play yet so
we hand-picked them so we so that this
way users can go there and be sure that
they're finding out about really cool
stuff that's actually still working
pretty well but be able to get that
feedback to developers get developers
like you a bit more exposure
and to help you be able to iterate more
quickly and improve your products and
this is a great way that we have a huge
reach in the Play Store and we're trying
to put this to work for you to help you
find early testers for your apps and get
the feedback that you folks need to
improve and get ready for a broader
launch okay and then okay so you have
your app you did a beta tests you got
some feedback it's looking pretty good
and you're ready to roll out so you roll
out to everybody and then once you've
done that the next time you run a roll
out a new version you can still beta
test your new versions as well but when
you're ready to put new updates to your
app out to everybody you'll probably
want to do what we do at Google and what
we see a lot of our top partners do
which is doing a staged rollout so I may
not want to roll out to everyone on day
one maybe I just want to start with 10%
then I'll monitor the reviews that I'm
getting maybe I'll use firebase to
monitor the crashes that are coming in
I'll see how it's doing and if I feel
confident 20% 30% 50% and then I'll roll
it out to everyone and here if there's a
major bug or if people just really don't
like the new color scheme my designer
came up with I can halt the rollout I
can immediately upload a new version if
I need to and then other people who
didn't have the new version yet won't be
affected by any negative issues that
were in my latest update one thing to
keep in mind though when you are in a
staged rollout people can leave reviews
so be sure it is good before you start
that
so another twin we've seen with
developers it's just the amount of time
that all of you spend managing your Play
Store reviews so we would talk to
developers and they say look the more
users I get the more reviews I get and
it's great but I have to have someone
sit there and read them all the time and
then try to have that person you know
summarized back to the team to
understand what a users like what are
they not like what should we do next and
so over the years we've been updating
what we have to make it easier for you
to manage so one of the unique things we
have is that you're actually able to
reply to reviews on the Play Store has
anyone done that by the way anyone
replied to review on the Play Store has
anyone thought about it but not done it
yet yeah it's worth considering we
definitely see that users who actually
update their review after receiving a
reply are actually increasing their
review on average by 0.7 stars so it's
definitely a good thing to think about
so that exists we've had you know search
on the reviews a whole range of graphs
we recently rolled out email
notifications so that if you get you
know someone updates their review again
you can find out so all these things are
to try to make reviews more friendly to
help you be able to dive into what's
happening with your reviews and how you
can manage them better because every app
that you get in every app review you get
in the Play Store it's really an
opportunity to have a one-on-one
interaction with a customer and I know
all of you care about your users as much
as we do and so having those tools to be
able to talk to them or understand
what's going on can be so important so
this year what we're just rolling out
now and we announced at i/o this week is
automated ways to be able to extract
more information out of the reviews for
you because developers would tell us
well I have to have someone sit there
and go through literally hundreds of
reviews right not that exciting and then
how does that person report back so
we've taken our machine learning
technologies and we're able to
automatically summarize them so we're
doing a couple things first of all
there's certain topics that are common
across all apps and we see coming up in
reviews all the time things like design
usability app stability and so what
we're doing is automatically identifying
any reviews that cite those sorts of
factors right are people talking about
your app crashing you know we'll be able
to surface that to you so you can just
dive in and see all the reviews that are
related to let's say crashes or maybe
you do a great new material design
layout you can look at all the feedback
about design to see if users are liking
your new layout and then a lot of
developers have asked us well are my
reviews good does my app measure up how
do I compare to my peers and so since
we're able to come look at your app
across these common topics that happen
to all apps we can now actually tell you
how your apps reviews in that particular
subject compared to similar apps so for
example are more people mentioning
crashes in your app compared to the
similar apps or more people mentioning
design for example and then you can also
see what the impact will be on your
rating so for example we see a lot of
people who if they have a lot of crashes
that users are mentioning that will be
dragging their review down usually if
those crashes are it's more of a
one-star type of rating but maybe a lot
of people love your new design
and you can see that that's having a
positive impact and pulling your rating
up and so that can be really helpful so
you can understand if I want to get my
rating up there what are the aspects
that I'm going to need to address all
right I want to go back one okay I can't
but the other thing I wanted to mention
about it is well that's interesting it
was magic
so the other thing I wanted to mention
about it too that it is an in addition
to these common topics your app probably
has unique features about it right maybe
you have a racing game and you have
different types of cars maybe you have a
fitness app and you have features like
pre-programmed workouts or calorie
counters or instructional videos and so
these unique features of your app will
also pull them out with our machine
learning and natural processing as well
so this way you can also see okay if I
launched a new feature like a new type
of car in my racing game how often is
that being mentioned and then more
importantly is that correlated with an
increase or decrease in my apps rating
so by looking at all these things
together it's we want to just make it
easier for you to see at a glance what
people are saying about your app and
also to help you zoom in you know we
hear all the time from startups I have
so much to do I'm overwhelmed with data
like just tell me what I should work on
and so we would love to hear your
feedback and understand if these new
reports are helping you zoom in on what
it is that you need to do next okay so
you have an app you beta tested it your
reviews are looking pretty good and now
what you want to do is start to go
bigger right and so you want to build
your audience so what we do on Google
Play is we launch the store listing
experiments feature last year and this
is a great way to be able to optimize
your store listing you want to know that
it's working well so what we do at
Google is we test everything and we
wanted to roll this out to you guys as
well so here are some best practices
with it you want to have a hypothesis
you know is it that your hypothesis is
that you know your fitness app people
really like the training video
capability so you want to emphasize that
or it's something else and then what you
want to do is to be able to run your
different experiments see what the
results are run it all the way to the
end and then a great thing about
startups is if you're brand
already well-established you can be
pretty bold and with you in which you're
what you're willing to experiment on
right a totally new icon go for it
the big changes are what's gonna get you
the biggest payoff so here's an example
of how Rovio was able to use a series of
experiments to get up to a pretty
significant increase by running these
experiments they had a double-digit
improvement in their conversion rate on
play and they had a lot of great things
to say about how it impacted their
business so that brings us to aviary
they're a start-up in New York they were
acquired by Adobe in 2004 and they've
been using some of the iteration tools
that we just discussed let's take a look
at this video I'm avi Muchnick I'm one
of the cofounders of aviary there are
thousands of photo editing apps out
there what we've always looked to do is
simplify the experience for the end-user
we want something that no matter what
your background in tech is you could
just literally pick it up and it's less
than six seconds understand how to use
it and make your photos look great one
of the most amazing things about the
Android platform is our communication
with our users it's not really us
responding to bug reports that we see
it's really this ongoing to a dialogue
we have with people both through beta
tests and also through ratings
interviews we can see things as they're
happening in real time we can talk with
our community to find out what features
they like and what they don't like and
what things they would love to see in
the app that we haven't even thought of
and implement that in real time working
with the Android dev console has been
amazing compared to other platforms in
particular with Android we are able to
see metrics about them we're able to
search through them were able to
actually respond to users with the new
tools I would say that we're able to
identify issues twice as fast it makes
it easy for us to search through the
reviews contact users when we need to
get more information from them and just
in general it has saved me a tremendous
amount of time anywhere between five to
ten hours a week
Android in general is hugely impactful
to the aviary team it's it's over
two-thirds of our user base we use
search within reviews every day we use
it to validate new features for example
we recently released a new discover
feature we'll search discover to see
what users are saying about that and let
us know if they like it or if there are
problems with it and that helps us to
make product decisions the ratings and
reviews feature has been immensely
impactful having the ability to quickly
drill into issues by device by app
version by Android version and then also
anecdotally sift through what users are
saying in the actual words they're using
is pretty unique to the platform and it
helps us develop much more quickly
responding to users in the dev console
has been immensely impactful for us for
instance recently we released a version
that I resolved a pretty major bug that
was affecting many of our users I went
into the dev console responded to all of
the people who are experiencing the bug
and about 50% of them actually went back
in and ended up updating the review one
of the things I loved about building for
the Android platform is how quickly we
can test and deploy on it we have this
fantastic beta community on Android that
can test out new features and that helps
us identify bugs or what features they
like or don't like much more quickly
being able to do that allows us to
iterate two to three times faster on
Android compared to other platforms
which is hugely impactful for our app
photo editor by aviary is meant to be a
dead simple but powerful photo editing
tool having that dialogue with our users
through the tools the developer console
and the Play Store gives us we're able
to iterate much faster and deliver on an
easy simple interface which is really
powerful for us
all right thank you very much it's been
great talking with all of you and we're
really excited to see what comes up next
for all of you I hope also all of you
will download the play console app on
Google Play and keep giving us your
feedback about how we can get better for
startups thank you